[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 1er février voici le
programme son incendie au mois de
novembre 2019 avait suscité une vive
émotion dans le département 3 ans après
le chapiteau de Chanteloup-les-Vignes a
été reconstruit nommé le phénix tout un
symbole c'est devenu la scène la mieux
équipée du département nous en parlerons
avec Catherine Arnaud la mère de la
commune elle est notre invitée jusqu'au
9 mars les lycéens est étudiants sont
invités à formuler leurs vœux sur la
plateforme parcoursup c'est dans ce
cadre que dans votre 7 8 nous vous
proposons tous les mercredis le portrait
d'une école du territoire ce soir focus
sur l'ESTACA l'école d'ingénieur
spécialisée dans les transports de
demain quels sont les filières qu'on
vient ça coûte comment y entrer nous
répondrons à toutes ces questions avec
un ancien étudiant et notre journaliste
Régine ralech et plaça la musique à vie
aux fans le groupe de rock Skip The Use
sera en concert au Théâtre de la Meurice
de Trappes ce vendredi 3 février il
présenteront leur cet album human
disorder un condensé d'émotion et nous
en parlerons avec Matt Bastard le leader
vocal du groupe et dans votre émission
nous parlerons aussi de cinéma bien
évidemment comme tous les mercredis ce
sera avec vous c'est ninja Charles vous
allez nous présenter les ciné les
sorties ciné de cette semaine de quoi
vous allez exactement alors je vais vous
parler bien sûr des nouvelles aventures
d'Astérix et Obélix le dernier film de
Night shiaman et un film d'animation
pour les plus jeunes et avec nous
également un régime ralech en plateau
bonsoir bonsoir vous allez nous
présenter les informations du jour mais
juste avant petit point sur la météo de
demain
matin le temps sera encore bien nuageux
sur l'ensemble des Yvelines au niveau
des températures il fera 5 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Rambouillet et 6
degrés à Versailles et Mantes-la-Jolie
dans l'après-midi le ciel devrait se
dégager dans le nord-ouest des Yvelines
mais les nuages seront toujours bien
présents dans le secteur de Versailles
et Rambouillet côté température il fera
10 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et aux dents
et 9 degrés à Versailles et Rambouillet
et demain il n'y aura pas de fête mais
ce sera la Chandeleur est-ce que vous
avez prévu de faire des crêpes Céline
Régine j'ai déjà commencé on m'a encore
commencé
et bien en tout cas je crois que demain
on a prévu de manger des crêpes ici à TV
78 le point maintenant sur l'actualité
dans les Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Régine rallès on
commence par l'image du jour c'est la
manifestation qui a eu lieu devant la
préfecture des Yvelines aujourd'hui tout
à fait Mathilde les associations et
syndicats engagés dans l'aide aux
étrangers ont rejoint le collectif bouge
ta préfecture le but est de protester
devant toutes les préfectures où là
préfecture en Île-de-France qui selon
les associations tarte à répondre et
mettent en péril certaines demandes de
renouvellement des titres de séjour on
écoute les réactions au micro de Julien
Leroy on est même dans le cadre de ce
qu'on appelle nous la fabrique de
nouveaux en papier ça veut dire des
caveux qui devraient avoir leur
promothétie du séjour comme les réfugiés
qui ont été déclarés réfugiés et qui
n'ont attendent un an ou un an et demi
c'est absolument invraisemblable il y en
a plein qui perdent leur travail qui
perdent leur emploi définitivement qui
sont mis à la rue qui ont pu les aides
les aides sociales disons que tous les
jours tous on est entre guillemets
harcelé par les étrangers qui eux-mêmes
sont dans la stress complet mon mariage
le 29 mai 2021 ça fait un an et quelques
mois maintenant je cherche un
rendez-vous à la préfecture pour un
titre de séjour vie privée familiale
mais j'ai été jamais répondu par la
préfecture après tant de tentative avec
des mails et encore des courriers on
continue avec le chiffre du jour c'est
22 pourquoi 22% c'est la hausse des
violences intrafamiliales dans les
Yvelines contre 17% à l'échelle
nationale ces chiffres ne viennent du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui vient de
rendre public les statistiques sur la
délinquance en France et le bilan est
sans appel la quasi-totalité des
indicateurs sont en hausse en 2022 par
rapport à l'année précédente plusieurs
types de violences sont recensés les
coûts et blessures volontaires les
violences intra-familiales ou encore les
violences sexuelles enregistrées par la
police et la gendarmerie un procès est
requis contre François Bayrou dans
l'affaire des assistants parlementaires
du MoDem lundi le parquet de Paris a
demandé que François Bayrou président du
MoDem et un certain nombre de dirigeants
de ce mouvement soit jugés par le
tribunal correctionnel dans l'affaire
dite des assistants parlementaires dans
l'entretien qui nous a accordé brune au
millième député MoDem des Yvelines
explique sur quels éléments repose cette
affaire il confirme aussi très
clairement l'affirmation de François
Bayrou selon laquelle la procédure
aurait contribué à aggraver la maladie
de Marielle de Cernay numéro 2 du MoDem
on écoute son interview express
[Musique]
que ce soit au niveau européen ou que ce
soit au niveau national c'est très
compliqué de faire une barrière entre
les travaux parlementaires qui incombe à
la mission des collaborateurs pour le
député auprès duquel ils sont attachés
de faire une vraie différence une vraie
barrière de sécurité entre l'action que
vous menez dans le Parlement dans lequel
vous exercez et le parti politique il
m'arrive de faire des missions ou de
faire des rapports dans le cadre de ma
mission de parlementaire
ces missions ou ces rapports sont
publiés et ils peuvent servir aussi à
mon parti politique pour organiser des
réunions alors est-ce que est-ce que mes
collaborateurs ont travaillé pour le
Parlement ou est-ce qu'ils ont aussi
travaillé pour le parti politique voilà
voilà où voilà où la frontière est
François Bayrou si procès il y a et moi
je souhaite qu'il y ait procès puisqu'il
a l'air sûr de lui pourra amener toutes
les preuves sur la table que non ce
n'était pas un système organisé comme on
a pu accuser d'autres parties de le
faire
[Musique]
comme beaucoup de mes collègues et comme
François avoir vécu
les derniers mois de sa maladie ou la
maladie s'est accélérée vraiment de
manière incroyable jusqu'à jusqu'à sa
disparition
oui elle était très affectée par cette
affaire et je pense très sincèrement que
ça a eu un effet accélérateur à la fois
de la maladie et de cette maladie qui
l'a emporté dès l'instant où jeter en
pâture des gens qui peut-être sont
innocents tant qu'il tant que le procès
n'a pas eu lieu en tout cas pour moi une
leçon ça peut avoir des effets induits
[Musique]
l'Île-de-France lance sa première
mutuelle régionale exactement Mathilde
dès aujourd'hui il est possible pour
tous les Franciliens de souscrire à
Île-de-France mutuelle santé l'offre
étant partenariat avec harmonie mutuelle
AXA et la mutuelle familiale elle
propose des tarifs attractifs jusqu'à
20% plus avantageux que ce
habituellement pratiqué en Île-de-France
le but est de faciliter l'accès à la
santé aux Franciliens les plus fragiles
pour plus d'informations vous pouvez
appeler gratuitement au 0800 73641 du
lundi au vendredi de 9h à 18h ou vous
rendre dans l'une des agences
partenaires et on termine ces infos du
jour avec la commune de Guyancourt qui
organise bientôt la 31ème édition du
Forum de la voie professionnelle oui et
ça se passera vendredi 3 février au
Pavillon Waldeck-Rousseau l'objectif est
de permettre aux jeunes de les aider
dans leur orientation au total 8
secteurs d'activités seront présentés
par une trentaine d'exposants toute la
journée des classes de collège et de
lycées vont venir sur le forum avec
leurs enseignants et puis entre 16h30 et
19h30 ils pourront s'accompagner de
leurs parents écoutez tout de suite
Richard Mézières adjo Omer en charge de
la jeunesse au micro de Julien Leroy sur
un seul lieu on a 34 exposants avec
différents domaines je crois qu'il y a
plus de il y a 8 domaines des domaines
de la sécurité on a l'armée qui est
présente avec tous les corps militaires
on a le domaine de la santé on a le
domaine du social du commerce et donc ça
permet sur une seule journée un seul
instant au collégien va devoir
différentes formations proposées et de
commencer à travailler sur ce qu'ils
veulent faire et de à travailler sur le
orientation et bien merci beaucoup
Régine rallès et puis comme d'habitude
si vous aussi vous voyez une information
qui vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager en
utilisant le hashtag 78
son incendie au mois de novembre 2019
avait suscité une vive émotion le
chapiteau de Chanteloup-les-Vignes René
de ses cendres baptisé le phénix il se
trouve au même emplacement que l'ancien
équipement culturel mais sans distingue
sur de nombreux aspects pour en parler
avec nous Catherine Arnoux bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes la mère de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes alors
l'inauguration du Phénix a eu lieu la
semaine dernière jeudi dernier un mot
tout d'abord peut-être sur l'émotion que
vous avez ressenti lors de cette soirée
un accomplissement peut-être alors
surtout surtout le fait que ce qui avait
été au départ pour nous soutenir en 2019
était aussi là pour nous accompagner en
c'est vrai un soutien beaucoup de
collectivités soutiennent des habitants
et soutient des forces associatives de
notre pays de beaucoup d'amis qui
avaient été là oui c'est ça a été une ça
a été une expérience un peu forte
d'arriver à reproduire redonner aux
habitants un équipement culturel de
qualité ça met un petit peu plus de
temps que prévu et même si tout le monde
pense que ça apparaît très court moi ça
m'a paru très long l'idée était vraiment
de donner un équipement culturel un peu
différent d'avance et mais aux habitants
parce qu'il le méritent bien et nos
équipes de TV 78 étaient présents à
cette inauguration regarde tout de suite
le reportage de régime ralech je suis
pas fière seulement je suis très
heureuse de vous accueillir ce soir
heureuse parce que en fait
l'inauguration de ce Phénix est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle à
Chanteloup-les-Vignes l'heure est à la
fête trois ans après l'incendie criminel
qu'il avait ravagé le chapiteau renaît
de ses cendres son nom est tout trouvé
le phénix
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup d'amour on se lève le
bonheur
ce cirque qui abrité une troupe de
théâtre se métamorphose en centre
artistique et numérique un véritable
symbole de célébration de la culture
pour la ville ça sera à la fois une
salle de cinéma ça sera la fois théâtre
ça sera le lieu de la danse au lieu de
la musique le lieu du hip-hop le lieu de
ce qu'on veut parce que l'idée c'est
qu'on nous surprenne et que les
habitants se la
propriété
d'inventer des formes nouvelles de
culture il aura fallu plus de 18 mois de
travaux pour ériger l'équipement de 650
mètres carrés les architectes se sont
inspirés des carrières souterraines de
gypse très présentes dans la région
pendant l'Antiquité on a voulu que cet
équipement reprenne cette forme
finalement de grandes grotte public qui
vient des sols
et pour faire son intérieur et donc le
bâtiment se déploie comme ça en grande
compte qui après va nous servir pour
faire le travail acoustique à
l'intérieur du bâtiment pour en faire
une salle de spectacle la ville de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes a pu compter sur
de nombreux soutiens dont la région
Île-de-France est le département des
Yvelines dès le lendemains de l'incendie
nous sommes venus pour annoncer que nous
financerions 100% du chapitre provisoire
qui allait être installé pendant les
travaux le temps qu'on reconstruit ce
magnifique équipement pour lequel la
région est engagée à hauteur de 40%. le
projet de cette salle aux finances à
concurrence d'un million et demi
c'est-à-dire presque la moitié mais
surtout le renouvellement urbain à
Chanteloup on veut finance à hauteur
environ 53% l'équipement est aussi doté
d'une tribune télescopique permettant
d'accueillir 200 personnes en
configuration assise
alors le phénix offre une salle de
spectacle de 240 place avec de la danse
du théâtre des concerts est-ce que vous
savez déjà quels sont les associations
qui vont pouvoir y habiter oui d'abord
les associations culturelles parce que
dans tous les vignes associe
particuliers c'est qu'il a beaucoup
l'amélias associatif très fort et entre
autres une grosse partie de la politique
culturelle qui est portée par des
associations culturelles y compris
l'association la compagnie des
contraires qui est à côté qui est à la
fois théâtre et cirque pour redonner le
contexte en fait c'est la même forme le
Phénix a la même forme qui avait forme
qui avait l'arche au départ c'est la
même structure c'est une structure tout
en bois sa composition me paraît
différente parce que les couleurs
extérieures ont été traitées
différemment mais elle est très très
différemment intérieurement puisque le
premier programme c'était un programme
qui était à la fois lieu culturel et a
lieu des arts du cirque et là devant
l'urgence on a installé on a fait
installer un chapiteau juste à côté donc
les arts du siècle reste dans un
chapiteau d'une façon plus
traditionnelle pour le cirque et donc la
salle devient une salle de spectacle ce
qui sur le plan acoustique et lumière et
plus beaucoup plus facile l'ensemble
cirque et et autres cultures étaient un
peu compliquées sur le plan technique
donc là maintenant on a à la fois une
salle de cinéma il se trouve qu'on a de
nombreux de nombreux actions cinéma à la
fois avec les écoles mais hors temps de
l'école pendant les temps quand c'est
tout ça qui vont trouver tout à fait
leur place ici on a une on a des
compagnies théâtrales bien évidemment on
a une on a une semaine théâtre qui a
lieu dans trois mois et qui va pouvoir
avoir lieu ici on a très régulièrement
une soirée cabaret une soirée une soirée
humour une soirée un week-end de jazz
donc tout ça ça va prendre sa place ici
donc il y a l'association
la programmation oui elle piétinait d'un
patience de pouvoir rentrer dans ces
lieux donc elle va s'installer tout de
suite et puis bien évidemment il y a
toute l'accompagnement musical entre
autres de des habitants de Chanteloup
par le projet d'emos par le projet
orchestre à l'école qui va pouvoir
trouver à la fois son lieu de répétition
et son lieu de démonstration aussi et ça
n'est pas rien que les jeunes puissent
montrer dans un cadre qui est qui a une
très belle sonorité une très belle
lumière montrer à leurs parents ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire et donc
vous venez de le dire et dans le
reportage on a entendu aussi il y a un
cinéma pourquoi cette volonté de
d'introduire un cinéma au sein du Phénix
alors parce que l'art du cinéma cette
année-là que les enfants doivent
connaître que on sort de l'ambiance
télévision qu'on peut travailler sur
l'art du cinéma que on était obligé
d'emmener les enfants dans les dans les
cinémas qui sont plutôt un peu lointain
enfin transport en commun ou transport
ou transports privés qui à chaque fois
est un peu compliqué et qui deviennent
plus en plus coûteux et puis c'est
intéressant quand même de faire des de
faire du travail au long cours sur des
œuvres cinématographiques qu'on peut
qu'on peut travailler sur place et donc
dans ce centre culturel c'est aussi un
centre numérique puisque le bâtiment
héberge un dispositif innovant nommé
microfolies alors le principe c'est
rendre accessible les oeuvres du Louvre
et des autres musées renommés à tous et
donc ça existe aussi aux Mureaux ça
fonctionne bien à Chanteloup alors ça va
fonctionner puisque ça ça c'est aussi le
lieu la coque de ce dispositif
de ce musée numérique en fait ce qu'on
voulait c'est que c'est que dans cette
dans ce centre culturel en plus
effectivement accueillir beaucoup de
culture alors c'est de la culture cinéma
c'est la culture du théâtre c'est la
culture de la musique c'est la culture
de la danse mais c'est aussi la culture
à la fois sculpture peinture tout ce
qu'on peut découvrir dans des musées en
fait ce dispositif est à dispositif
porté par l'État c'est une c'est une
association avec la Villette qui porte
ce dispositif au départ et puis un
certain nombre de musée de France et en
fait on travaille sur des thèmes ça peut
être ça peut s'approprier ça peut les
écoles peuvent se l'approprier il suffit
de travailler sur un thème je vais vous
donner un exemple on travaille
l'impressionnisme on travaille la façon
dont Manet des dessiner cordes dessinées
les tissus et à ce moment-là vous pouvez
venir
sur dans ce lieu et vous avez à la fois
un phénomène de tablette et de grand
écran qui vous permet de travailler au
plus près sur des thèmes donnés tout ce
que vous pourriez voir dans un musée
tout ça accompagné évidemment des
enseignants et puis de professionnels
qui accompagneront les enfants c'est
aussi ça peut être le club senior qui
s'en empare c'est bien évidemment les
associations culturelles mais pas que
c'est l'occasion aussi de travailler sur
des thèmes qu'on peut voir ailleurs mais
qui qui permet d'enrichir aussi un peu
le regard et ça va ouvrir quand alors le
plus vite possible j'espère d'ici un
mois et alors du coup on en parlait
aussi un petit peu par son architecture
c'est devenu l'enceinte la mieux équipée
acoustiquement on a entendu c'est par
rapport aux grottes de gypse c'est une
fierté je suppose
un objectif l'objectif c'était de
redonner un lieu culturel de très belle
qualité pour les chantes Louvain il se
trouve qu'effectivement à la fois les
structures et la structure telle qualité
fabriquée les matériaux utilisés ont
encouragé les spécialistes du saut et de
l'image pour donner une très belle
qualité une très belle qualité de son et
une très belle qualité d'image sur un
lieu qui est à la hauteur de Chanteloup
c'est de dire que c'est pas Bercy on est
bien d'accord c'est un lieu qui
accueille qui va accueillir 240
personnes qui est la jauge nécessaire
pour l'ensemble des actions culturelles
de la ville alors coût total des travaux
3,4 millions d'euros avec une aide de
385000 euros de la région et 1,5
millions d'euros du département merci
beaucoup Catherine Arnaud d'être venu en
parler avec nous je le répète la mère de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes au revoir
dimanche dernier Jean-Noël barreau le
ministre chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
présentées ses vœux aux habitants de son
ancienne circonscription des Yvelines la
deuxième l'occasion pour nous de revenir
sur ses premiers mois au gouvernement
l'interview de Gabriel Gontier
[Musique]
la mission de ce ministère c'est
d'humaniser le numérique d'abord en
essayant d'obtenir une forme d'autonomie
d'indépendance de maîtrise des
technologies qui demain vont dessiner le
quotidien de nos concitoyens
et ça ça suppose évidemment d'investir
dans l'innovation l'intelligence
artificielle le Cloud le quantique et
nous avons tous les atouts pour réussir
en France et en Europe la deuxième
mission c'est évidemment de garantir à
chacune et à chacun l'accès à l'espace
numérique et ça c'est tout l'enjeu de la
fin du déploiement de la fibre des
réseaux mobiles mais aussi
l'accompagnement humain pour celles et
ceux qui rencontrent des difficultés
pour accéder aux services numériques
[Musique]
on continue à protéger un à un les
établissements de santé les
collectivités les grands établissements
publics pour qu'ils soient armés face à
cette menace qui se généralise et qui
progresse et puis par ailleurs mon
objectif c'est de garantir la
cybersécurité du quotidien à nos
concitoyens et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous travaillons à la mise en
place d'un d'un filtre anti-arnac qui
viendra sur tous les smartphones sur
tous les ordinateurs prévenir nos
concitoyens lorsque il s'oriente ou il
se dirige vers un site considéré comme
malveillant
il y a un gros travail qui est mené nous
avons en France des acteurs reconnus
mondialement pour leur savoir-faire en
matière de cybersécurité je pense à Atos
je pense à Thalès et puis à toutes les
startups de la cyber donc je souhaite
qu'elle puisse évidemment jouer un rôle
important dans la protection des sites
et pour éviter ou pour riposter face aux
milliards de tentatives d'intrusion
qu'un manquablement nous allons subir
pendant cette période où l'Île-de-France
et la France seront sous le feu des
projecteurs
je voudrais insister plus
particulièrement sur la protection des
mineurs dans quelques semaines je
présenterai un dispositif de
vérification d'âge fiable
respectueux de la vie privée qui pourra
être utilisé pour une bonne fois pour
toute restreindre l'accès à certains
sites indésirables je pense aussi de
pornographiques en particulier à nos
enfants
[Musique]
comme chaque mercredi maintenant nous
partons à la découverte d'une école dans
les Yvelines et c'est avec vous
régineralesh vous allez nous parler de
l'ESTACA ce soir tout à fait Mathilde je
vais vous parler de l'ESTACA cette école
fondée en 1925 forme des ingénieurs dans
le domaine des transports et tous les
transports puisque les filières
proposées passent par le domaine de
l'aéronautique le ferroviaire
l'aérospatiale l'automobile ou encore la
filière navale les staccas est aussi
trois campus en France à Laval à
Bordeaux et à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
depuis 2015 elle compte également 2600
étudiants 400 diplômés chaque année et
40 associations étudiantes elle présente
également d'excellents chiffres puisque
98% des étudiants sont embauchés dans
les deux mois qui suivent la remise des
diplômes et elle se place à la 9e
position des écoles d'ingénieurs
post-bac par l'Usine Nouvelle les stacs
comptent également d'anciens élèves
notoires on peut citer par exemple
Frédéric Vasseur le nouveau directeur de
la de la Scud Ferrari pour en parler de
cette école on est avec nous un ancien
étudiant il n'a pas encore la carrière
de Frédéric Vasseur mais on lui souhaite
lui Orthus on va parler un peu de votre
parcours vous êtes ingénieur en
amélioration continue qu'est-ce que
c'est alors ben en général son continue
il y a plusieurs rôles souvent qu'on est
dans une entreprise dans ce type de
poste là où je suis donc apprends engin
j'ai on va dire deux grands rôles c'est
tout d'abord d'être au contact des
opérateurs toute la journée donc essayer
de remonter le plus possible les
problèmes qui peut y avoir par rapport
au système de production qu'on a mis en
place et puis il y a une autre partie on
va faire de l'implantation de chantier
c'est à dire mettre en place des
nouvelles lignes de production et
essayer de les améliorer au fur et à
mesure pour que les loisirs que toutes
les personnes qui travaillent dans le
système de production travaille dans des
manières de manière qualitative avec des
bons rendements et puis avec la plus
grande sécurité possible aussi et alors
comment est-ce que vous avez intégré
l'ESTACA alors les stockages donc je
l'ai intégré donc c'est une école qui
est post-bac de base donc j'ai fait
évidemment une
scientifique avec une option
physique-chimie et donc après je l'ai
intégré avec donc parcoursup en faisant
ma demande donc à l'époque je crois que
ça plaît encore APB admission post-bac
et donc à ce moment-là j'ai fait la
demande directement sur APB et j'ai été
pris ce qu'on appelle en grand classique
c'est-à-dire que je n'ai pas eu à passer
le concours parce qu'il faut savoir que
pour entrer dans cette école en fait
faut passer normalement concours qui
s'appelle concours à venir et donc les
personnes qui ont un dossier suffisant
peuvent ne pas passer ce concours et
directement être pris sur dossier quoi
donc vous avez été pris parce que vous
aviez une bonne moyenne oui c'est ça
après ça dépend aussi du lycée dans
lequel on est souvent ils vont faire on
va dire une moyenne entre on va dire
notre position dans la classe parce
qu'ils ont accès au moyen des autres
aussi et puis le lycée d'où on vient qui
peut aussi jouer dans le dossier est-ce
que vous avez des conseils pour passer
une bonne scolarité au sein de les stats
on passe une bonne scolarité le conseil
que j'ai c'est d'un point de vue
scolaire c'est d'abord d'être vraiment
assidu sur en tout cas vraiment les
premières années parce que c'est une
école qui est vraiment pas facile enfin
après moi je l'ai vécu comme ça il y en
a certains ils ont vécu une manière
différente c'est une école qui va être
très dure tous les deux premières années
parce que c'est une prépa intégrée en
fait donc un peu comme quand on fait une
prépa et en intégrer une grande école
derrière donc surtout sur les premières
années et puis après ne pas hésiter à
vraiment aller dans les associations
découvrir tout ça parce que ça permet de
se faire des contacts ça permet de
d'apprendre de l'expérience et surtout
ça qui nous sert après derrière dans
notre métier et justement vous avez
choisi quelle filière j'ai choisi la
filière aéronautique et ça on l'a choisi
donc c'est une filière qu'on choisit en
troisième année d'école
alors dans cette filière on va voir
plusieurs alors ça dépend des années
mais sur les premières années par
rapport par exemple à l'aéronautique on
va d'abord travailler sur des projets
qui sont type aéronautiques mais aussi
les matières assez scolaires vont être
orientées vers vers l'aéronautique
on a eu l'occasion de travailler avec
aussi des entreprises sur des projets
différentes entreprises c'est un on va
dire une expérience qu'on a en 4e année
c'est un gros projet qu'on a toute
l'année et qui nous permet en fait de
d'être au contact avec une entreprise et
de réaliser un projet avec l'entreprise
et donc aujourd'hui vous évoluez dans le
domaine de l'armée pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez fait ce choix j'ai fait soit
parce que je l'ai découvert leur dans
mon stage de deuxième année j'avais
réalisé au chantier Atlantique qui est
donc une grande entreprise très dans le
domaine naval qui est basée à
Saint-Nazaire et durant ce stage en fait
j'ai travaillé sur un projet militaire
et c'est ça qui m'a directement donné
envie de travailler dans le domaine de
la défense parce qu'il faut savoir que
par exemple même dans l'aéronautique il
y a une grande partie civile évidemment
mais il y a aussi une grande partie
militaire qui est de plus en plus
importante surtout avec la situation
actuelle donc vous êtes rentrés en stage
est-ce que c'est difficile justement de
trouver des stages dans dans ces
filières de manière générale alors ça
peut être difficile comme
on va dire que depuis le la crise du
covid ça a été un peu compliqué de
trouver de trouver des stages après ça
va on s'améliorant de plus en plus avant
le covid c'était très très facile que ce
soit dans l'automobile aéronautique le
ferroviaire mais on va dire que depuis
ouais 2020 c'est un peu plus compliqué
mais ça commence à revenir surtout dans
le domaine aéronautique où il y a de
plus en plus d'offres donc faut vraiment
pas hésiter à aller sur le site des
entreprises et à passer aussi par en
tout cas je parle pour les stickers par
la partie on va dire un peu RH de
l'estaquais qui nous permet de créer des
dossiers d'envoyer à certaines
entreprises il faut vraiment se
renseigner là-dessus
en rentrant dans cette école du coup
quand on en sort justement qu'est-ce
qu'il y a comme métier concret par
exemple dans l'aéronautique ou dans le
ferroviaire
comme métier concret un des métiers les
plus concrets c'est business manager
c'est souvent des gens qui vont aller
donc ça c'est beaucoup il y a beaucoup
de postes comme ça qui nous sont
proposés donc on va aller au contact des
grandes entreprises pour un
sous-traitant et on va un peu voyager ça
c'est un peu souvent qui fait un peu
rêver on est souvent amené à voyager
pour aller au contact des clients pour
comprendre leurs besoins et puis pouvoir
créer du coup d'ailleurs ses besoins
dans l'entreprise ou alors par exemple
un poste qui que j'aurais pu aussi faire
c'était de l'exploitation et maintenant
c'est à dire être par exemple dans des
ateliers aéronautiques par exemple chez
je vais pas citer le nom mais je suis
une grande compagnie aérienne où on va
être donc au contact des hommes toute la
journée avec les opérateurs pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir un peu étudier comment
améliorer la maintenance des moteurs la
maintenance de l'avion en général donc
c'est des postes qui sont assez concrets
et qui nous sont proposés directement
après après notre cursus selon vous
c'est quoi la force de l'ESTACA en
entendu les chiffres 98% de réussite
mais ce que il y a autre chose
alors l'ESTACA c'est une entreprise qui
se déjà depuis longtemps donc c'est
forgé un réseau dans les grandes
entreprises ce qui fait que maintenant
quand on va dans une grande entreprise
les stockage souvent une école qui est
connue donc ça ça nous aide souvent sur
on va dire
nos entretiens forcément mais du coup on
a aussi de derrière on a aussi un peu
stressé par rapport à ça parce qu'il y a
une attente derrière des entreprises
d'avoir quand même une qualité sur sur
tous les on fait tous les points qu'on
doit aborder lors des entretiens mais je
pense que c'est quoi ce qui fait la
force c'est la renommée et puis et puis
en vrai le panel de choses qu'on voit
quand même en 5 ans même si c'est
toujours c'est jamais assez suffisant
sur cinq ans on s'en rend compte quand
on sort de l'école mais ouais la grande
force de stockage je pense que c'est
tout ce qui est renommé voilà alors
rapidement dernière question ça coûte
combien les frais de scolarité dans
cette école c'est autour des donc pour
les 5 ans c'est autour des
40.000 euros et ça commence à un peu
évoluer depuis quelques années comme
beaucoup d'écoles
donc voilà autour des 40.000 euros pour
les 5 ans après on peut rentrer aussi en
3e année après un autre cursus par
exemple une prépa donc on paiera que les
trois années par exemple mais si on veut
rentrer dès le bas enfin juste après le
bac c'est simple enfin c'est 40000 euros
pour les 50
accepté notre invitation et d'être venu
parler de votre ancienne école l'ESTACA
on vous souhaite beaucoup de réussite
direction l'Italie maintenant grâce à
l'association aFS Vivre Sans Frontières
aurélian Damie une jeune yvelinoise de
15 ans est partie en Italie pour suivre
une année de scolarité à l'étranger elle
est accueillie par une famille d'accueil
bénévole et justement elle est connectée
à distance avec nous bonsoir Aurélienne
bonsoir alors comment ça s'est passé vos
premiers mois est-ce que ça n'a pas été
trop dur de quitter le cocon familial
alors les premiers mois sont souvent les
plus difficiles car c'est à ce moment où
on rencontre la famille les amis et on
commence vraiment à se construire une
vie mais là ça fait 5 mois que je suis
là et je suis vraiment épanouie et tout
se passe super bien donc voilà c'est
super justement ça se passe comment
votre quotidien au sein de la famille
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance avec ma
famille car on s'entend vraiment super
bien mais oui ça se passe super bien on
est vraiment je me sens vraiment comme
un membre de la famille et ils sont
adorables avec moi on s'entend sur tous
les sur tous les critères comme j'ai
vraiment beaucoup de chance même
beaucoup d'affections au quotidien tous
dont j'ai besoin il me fournissent et
avec plaisir vous saviez déjà un petit
peu parlé italien avant de partir ça pas
été trop difficile d'apprendre une
nouvelle langue
alors j'avais fait un an au lycée
l'italien spinéralement pas beaucoup
enfin c'était juste pour apprendre un
peu les bases mais directement en fait
quand on s'immerge dans le dans le pays
on est obligé d'apprendre vraiment la
langue car on voit bien que les gens
sont pas patients et qui vont pas
attendre 10 mois pour pour commencer à
vraiment se connaître donc j'ai répondu
m'y mettre à fond quand je suis arrivée
à lire en italien il y a des séries en
italien à parler et à faire des beaucoup
d'efforts et maintenant ça va c'est
parfait et aussi l'italien très très
similaire aux Français donc ça a
beaucoup aidé aussi enfin il suffisait
seulement de rajouter un petit bout de
parole et ça fonctionnait vous
recommanderiez du coup cette expérience
a d'autres jeunes
oui moi vraiment je ne regrette
absolument pas c'est incroyable de
pouvoir partir un an à seulement 16 ans
c'est vraiment une prise de conscience
aussi ça apporte beaucoup en maturité et
aussi surtout découvrir la culture d'un
nouveau pays au quotidien c'est
incroyable vraiment je le recommande à
100%
ça serait vraiment ça fait vraiment
faire une prise de compte incroyable
difficulté vous avez pu rencontrer au
quotidien déjà la barrière de la langue
mais est-ce qu'il y en a eu d'autres
peut-être
c'est un peu compliqué d'arriver dans un
pays où on connaît absolument rien donc
forcément c'est logique qu'il va y avoir
des moments on va se sentir triste on va
se sentir seul
avec les amis surtout c'était un peu
compliqué parce que en faisant un groupe
d'amis qu'est-ce qu'on a depuis très
très longtemps et forcément ils ont que
ils sont ces adolescents c'était un peu
difficile mais c'est vraiment faut être
patient et avec le temps tout comment ça
se à se mettre en place et sinon à part
ça Noël c'est un peu compliqué aussi
d'être dans l'ami de pas mais à part ça
c'était vraiment c'est pas trop
compliqué
et alors qu'est-ce que vous avez
découvert sur la culture italienne
alors moi c'est un peu compliqué car je
suis dans un dans la religion dans la
région du cityrol donc c'est un mélange
entre l'Italie et l'Allemagne mais déjà
les pâtes c'est pas c'est pas un
stéréotype il mange vraiment des pâtes
tous les jours tout le temps des qui
peuvent ensuite la langue italienne
n'est pas seulement la langue mais aussi
les mains c'est beaucoup les mains les
gestes c'est incroyable aussi j'adore et
puis sinon c'est aussi beaucoup de
moments de famille sont très très
proches de leur famille et pour eux les
moments le week-end de faire au moins un
jour une sortie familiale c'est super
important c'est sinon c'est très très
mal élevé de pas de pas vouloir partager
ces moments donc moi ça me va vraiment
beaucoup parce que j'aime beaucoup
passer des moments en famille faire des
choses comme ça donc voilà et du coup
vous avez prévu de revenir en France
c'est à la fin de l'année scolaire c'est
bien ça
oui donc au total je reste 10 mois donc
je rentrerai à la fin en juillet et bien
une dernière question Céline c'était
juste pour savoir vous apprendre vous
appréhendez un peu le retour en France
ou ça vous manque un petit peu de
retrouver vos parents vos proches
je dirais pas que ça me manque mais
c'est vrai que c'est un peu une
infection pour
changer de vie comme ça aussi facilement
je pense que ça va être très très
compliqué de rentrer parce que moi
honnêtement j'ai pas trop envie de
rentrer
mais je pense que ça va le faire le
temps je formerai habituer mais c'est
vrai que partir de cette vie que j'ai
créée que j'ai vraiment je sens super
bien partir au bout de 10 mois et
laisser tout ça pour la vie quoi puisque
je pourrais pas revenir au lycée ça
serait très très dur je pense mais c'est
la vie
et bien merci beaucoup Aurélienne d'amis
de vous être connecté à distance avec
nous il y a deux autres yvelinoises qui
sont partis grâce à l'association aFS
Vivre Sans Frontières Rosa en Argentine
et Ariel aux États-Unis
et comme chaque mercredi on enchaîne
avec la page cinéma avec le coup de
coeur signé d'un professionnel du 7e art
cette semaine c'est la réalisatrice Jena
sur rue qui vous propose son coup de
cœur regardez
[Musique]
le film que je recommande et robot de
Adil et Larbi et Bilal Falla qui est un
film absolument époustouflant une
coproduction Belgo luxembourgeoise
l'été dernier s'est rendu en Syrie comme
[Musique]
tu es mon fils je t'aime
sur un petit garçon
malheureusement se rendent en Syrie pour
de mauvaises raisons et ce que je trouve
absolument fantastique dans ce film
c'est que je crois vraiment que les
réalisateurs voulaient montrer un
message tout à fait éducationnel sans
pointer le doigt à qui que ce soit mais
plutôt au contraire montrer la réalité
expliquer le processus qui
malheureusement parfois conduit à ce
type d'aliénation qui peut toucher
vraiment toutes les classes sociales et
tous les âges
[Musique]
des acteurs était d'une justesse
vraiment très très frappante c'est un
film aussi que j'ai beaucoup apprécié
dans le cadre de sa projection en séance
de minuit au Festival de Cannes puisque
les réactions dans la salle du Grand
Théâtre lumière à cette heure tardive
était d'autant plus forte lorsque l'on
vit vraiment la réalité sur le terrain
et je crois que ce message d'éducation
est finalement de pas tourner le dos à
la réalité c'est vrai que c'est toujours
difficile de de faire face à des choses
qui soient absolument épouvantables mais
parfois c'est important aussi de pouvoir
faire passer des messages et comprendre
la réalité ne pas lui tourner le dos
pour pouvoir mieux la confronter
tu vas faire partie de cette vidéo comme
pour eux comme fiction toi de choisir
[Musique]
place à la musique maintenant Skip The
Use sera en concert vendredi soir sur la
scène de la Merise à Trappes et nous
sommes en compagnie de Matt Bastard
leader vocal du groupe de rock bonsoir
bonsoir vous m'entendez bien tout va
bien
vous avez album human disorder en mars
2022 il traite beaucoup des
avec les confinements qu'est-ce qu'il
raconte concrètement cet album
concrètement on a essayé de faire un peu
une photo du monde on fait toujours ça
nous dit ce qu'on essaie de faire une
photo du monde dans lequel on vit un
instant T
et voilà elle se trouve qu'à ce
moment-là on est en train de vivre une
période extraordinaire on était confinée
on était toute la planète à lutter
contre contre un virus et on s'est
retrouvé dans des situations qu'on
vivait pas souvent bah comme être en
famille alors que d'habitude on est sur
la route donc c'était des moments aussi
très intéressants très riche et
tout dès qu'il y a un carrefour
émotionnel c'est tout de suite
intéressant d'en faire un disque et donc
on voit les premières chansons c'est
plutôt une ambiance un peu sombre et
puis les dernières chansons on me fait
place plutôt à la lumière c'était
c'était une volonté du coup de le faire
dans cet ordre là
ouais on a essayé de nous notre but
c'est on est on est plutôt vers à moitié
plein que vers à moitié vide donc on est
assez positif
on est voilà on aime on aime espérer que
on peut trouver une lumière au bout du
tunnel ensemble en tout cas
quoi qu'il en soit ça passera toujours
pour la cohésion et par quelque chose de
collectif et
voilà et c'est ce qu'on s'en aperçoit
sur scène surtout que les dates de la
tournée quoi vous avez plutôt une vision
optimiste vous avez aussi choisi de
chanter quatre chansons en français
alors qu'avant vous chantiez plus
généralement en anglais là aussi c'était
une volonté
c'est ça se prêtait aux chansons qu'on
avait envie de mettre en avant
tout simplement il y avait aucune autre
velléité derrière ça il y a pas de
stratégie ou on n'est pas très
stratégique nous comme groupe
voilà on avait envie de les faire comme
ça on les a fait
et on va parler de votre single The One
Two mais juste avant je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait
[Musique]
dans nos veines c'est qu'on ne parfois
tu sais ça en vaut la peine on a fermé
les yeux mais on n'a pas quitté Ken quoi
qu'il en coûte en récolte c'est que
c'est alors cette chanson elle est très
intime puisqu'elle parle de votre
relation amoureuse avec votre femme en
théâtre c'est une déclaration d'amour
cette chanson
bah oui oui c'est surtout un grand merci
de de d'avoir la possibilité de pas
affronter la vie tout seul et c'est une
vraie chance
et le clip il est en
tous les jours
le clip il est aussi en version animée
ça aussi c'était une volonté
on aime bien on aime bien l'animation on
a toujours aimé ça avec le projet on
avait fait plusieurs clips
de cet ordre là et
ouais on avait envie de le faire comme
ça s'y prêtait bien à quoi peuvent
s'attendre les Yvelinois qui ne vous ont
jamais vu en concert
ils peuvent s'attendre à
vivre une expérience qui
avec des gens qui connaissent pas et à
faire des choses qui s'étaient pas
attendues à faire c'est à dire
bah je pense que aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de spectacles où les gens ils
viennent au cinéma ou regarder un truc
qui sont assis et puis on leur propose
un programme et puis ils aiment ils
aiment pas nous on n'aime pas ça on aime
bien faire un concert avec les gens que
le public soit acteur du concert qui va
voir et on fait la soirée tous ensemble
et on se lâche tous ensemble donc il
faut s'attendre à tout
et ça donnera rien en même temps ça
dépend de ce que tu veux
sans vous allez chanter
beaucoup c'est pour ça on sait même pas
à quelle heure on va finir
et du coup vous avez d'autres projets à
venir d'autres albums ou travailler sur
quelque chose en ce moment
là déjà on va chez la tournée après il y
a les festivals d'été on a des élites
qui commencent en octobre
et puis en même temps oui on travaille
sur des nouveautés des collaborations
un nouvel album mais ça bon on est
toujours en train de faire de la musique
donc je pense que c'est c'est jamais
c'est tous ces permanent le fait de
faire de nouvelles choses
pour pour cette entretien et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
si vous le vendredi 3 février à 20h30
sur la scène de la maryse attrape les
places vont de 12 à 27 euros et on va
poursuivre du coup cette page cinéma on
a vu le coup de coeur ciné mais
maintenant ce sont les sorties ciné avec
vous c'est ninja on commence par le
premier film que vous nous proposez
c'est un film très attendu où l'on voit
le retour de deux personnages
emblématiques et oui il s'agit bien sûr
d'Astérix et Obélix plus de 10 ans après
au service de Sa Majesté les deux héros
gaulois prennent le chemin de l'Empire
du Milieu on retrouve Guillaume Canet
derrière et devant la caméra sous les
traits d'Astérix il donnera la réplique
à Gilles Lellouche en Obélix dans ce
film nous sommes toujours en 50 avant
Jésus-Christ et l'impératrice de Chine
est emprisonné à la suite d'un coup
d'État sa fille la princesse fouille fui
la Chine atterrit en Gaule où elle va
demander l'aide d'Astérix et Obélix
ensemble ils vont se lancer dans une
quête en Chine pour délivrer
l'impératrice regardez
le nouvel empereur de Chine
et mon nom restera gravé dans le marbre
de l'histoire j'adore quand tu dis ça
j'adore atelier du bien et du bien
pourquoi faut-il toujours qu'on vient de
nous demander de l'aide à nous non mais
non moi je suis d'accord j'ai rien en ce
moment
je t'arrête d'après c'est on va se
marier tu sais quoi bélix tu seras
inventé moi c'est pas vrai il est en
train de lui parler en train de relancer
vous faites quoi là rien
je vais vous montrer comment se bagarre
en Chine
alors dans cette comédie à sketch on
retrouve comme on a pu le voir un
casting de stars Vincent Cassel Marion
Cotillard Jonathan Cohen ou encore José
Garcia des invités font également leur
apparition comme la chanteuse Angèle
vous les youtubeurs McFly et Carlito
vous nous proposez un autre rendez-vous
Céline il s'agit d'un thriller cette
fois-ci et oui Mathilde est autour de la
table qu'est-ce que vous feriez si on
vous demandez de choisir entre sauver le
monde et sacrifier un membre de votre
famille le dilemme
sauver le monde
voilà alors en tout cas c'est le dilemme
moral du film knock à deux cabines du
réalisateur naïcha Malan à qui on doit
aussi le film split ou sixième sens
alors il revient avec un nouveau
thriller un huis clos à frissons ou le
destin de l'humanité repose sur les
épaules d'une seule famille composée
d'une petite fille de ces deux papas le
trio passe leurs vacances dans un chalet
isolé en pleine forêt lorsqu'ils vont
être prises en otage par quatre
étrangers dont et d'ailleurs interprété
par Rupert Grint dans Harry Potter alors
c'est quatre inconnus vont exiger de ce
choix impossible pour éviter
l'Apocalypse imminente
nous avons été appelés et sommesunis par
une vision commune qui maintenant
s'impose à nous comme un ordre que nous
ne pouvons ignorer
[Musique]
nous sommes ici tous les quatre
pour empêcher l'Apocalypse
votre famille a été élu pour faire un
choix épouvantable
on y parvenez pas ce sera la fin du
monde
alors est-ce qu'ils ont à faire à des
complotistes ou est-ce qu'ils ont
vraiment l'avenir de l'humanité entre
leurs mains réponse dans les salles ça a
l'air un peu glace quand même ça fait
peur on termine avec de la légèreté
Céline Maurice le chat fabuleux un film
d'animation pour les plus jeunes tout à
fait un film signé Toby Ganga et
Floriane westerman après le Chat Potté
c'est un autre chat roux qui débarque
sur les écrans dans ce film on fait la
connaissance de Maurice un chat qui a
imaginé avec l'aide de son copain humain
et de ses compères les rats une arnaque
parfaite il passe de rue en rue pour
chasser les rats contre des pièces d'or
alors qu'ils sont en réalité complices
mais lorsqu'ils arrivent dans une
nouvelle ville ils vont vite tomber sur
plus fort que et se rendre compte qu'une
puissance magique est à l'oeuvre la fine
équipe va tenter de résoudre ce mystère
la voix de Maurice de Maurice c'est
ugliot Laurie qui interprète Dr House
mais vous allez également retrouver les
voix d'Emilia Clark et David Tennant
entre autres pour la version originale
merci beaucoup Céline Charles est-ce que
vous avez une préférence autour du
plateau sur sur un des trois films
[Rires]
et vous Céline moi je pense que je vais
me laisser tenter par le thriller
j'adore les thriller à chaque fois vous
me pose plus que les comédies
et c'est la fin c'est bientôt la fin de
cette émission mais juste avant jetons
un coup d'œil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le temps sera encore bien
nuageux sur l'ensemble des Yvelines au
niveau des températures il fera à 5
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et Rambouillet
et 6 degrés à Versailles et
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
ciel devrait se dégager dans le
nord-ouest des Yvelines mais les nuages
seront toujours bien présents dans le
secteur de Versailles et Rambouillet
côté température il fera 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan et 9 degrés à
Versailles et Rambouillet et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivie jusqu'au bout avec nous je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]